funny is for years homeschoolers have
been called like the weird kids right
isn't that interesting how the the
script got flipped and the homeschooler
almost every homeschool kid I know is
well adjusted like they are talkative
they're mature they're social beyond
belief and it's the public so many
public school kids can't seem to handle
socialization I was going over
um some studies on exactly this and one
of the questions that I had was that is
that really true and they found that
it's actually the opposite home school
kids are actually more apt in Social
settings than the public school it's
reverse from what the narrative has
become or thought and if you think about
it it makes no sense you need 3 000
people to socialize yeah that's not how
socializing works yeah I think that's
another thing people have been waking up
to just like you just said I see it and
we all see it